[Music]
first impressions matter first time and
this is doubly true for anime villains
in fact i'd go out and say one thing
that separates mediocre and just good
villains from the truly memorable ones
happens to be the way they debut from
their first appearance they must strike
fear into the hearts of feeble mortals
or at least do something super cool that
fans will remember them for first i'll
be sharing what i feel are the best
moments of villains making an excellent
first impression join me as we go
through some of the most memorable
debuts in action anime
after seasons of mostly fighting titans
it's about time for a change of pace and
what we've got is someone who doesn't
really have as much of an imposing
presence as the shifters but is just as
or even more dangerous in the serial
killer kenny ackerman i've covered this
moment before as one of my favorites
simply because of the scene's masterful
use of atmosphere the whole time you the
audience are at the edge of your seats
due to the ominous ambience the supposed
calm does carry an air of impending doom
and levi's own monologues reflect what a
lot of us thought in that moment
something's wrong and we know it's
coming
it's just that we can't do anything
about it then it happens people drop
like flies and levi's left to confront
this new villain with unbridled fury he
may have been an expert in titan combat
but one of the battle is against one of
his own and someone with far more
malicious and murderous intent than the
behemoths it's an amazing way to put a
cliffhanger on attack on titan's season
three's pilot episode the magazine's
good but what the anime did made it even
more amazing
since we're on the topic of a series
about people transforming into
monstrosities remember goto from
parasite
watching parasite i didn't exactly know
what the end game was at the start yeah
there's the hole protecting humans from
alien invader schtick but there's gotta
be a mastermind right you know a big
boss who when defeated will put an end
to this madness it's one of the
mysteries that keeps my anticipation up
for the plot of this excellent series
then comes this big squinty-eyed guy
some guy claiming to just test his
limitations while slaughtering the
yakuza like they're nothing he moves
with superhuman speed while using his
bare hands to attack what amazes me more
though is how he easily shrugs off
literal bullets and swords to show his
power the mask comes off after the
massacre and with the appearance that
we've come to know it's here that i
finally knew this is the guy this is the
one who's gonna have that epic showdown
with shinichi at some point true final
boss material and let me just say that
their eventual confrontation didn't
disappoint it had no shortage of drama
and heart-pounding action
we move on from aliens to heroes with
our next entry garro
[Music]
one punch man second season decided to
go for a change of pace instead of a
somewhat episodic approach that the
first season pulled the second season
quickly sets the tone by introducing an
overarching villain to be dealt with in
a series with powerhouse heroes and
overpowered villains like boros the
pressure is huge and garo rises to the
challenge in his debut eventually taking
on the role of a hero hunter is a
daunting task that's not for the weak
nor the faint of heart so how does garo
show us that he's up to the task of
becoming the strongest by pulling a
one-man army and defeating everyone in
sight it doesn't matter whether he's
facing a group of heroes and villains at
once the strongest in the world must be
able to assert supremacy right the bad
news is that he's only getting started
his crusade against heroes is quite the
compelling plot point to follow but
something like that is only as good as
the debut in that regard he made a damn
good first impression
[Music]
meruem is next on the list as everyone
would have expected
meruem is the character who wastes no
time in making an impact that's taken
quite literally as he's the villain that
we have the pleasure of seeing as early
as birth what does he do that's right
force his way out of the queen ant oh
and kill comrades as well shocking but
not completely unexpected from someone
who's destined to be the king something
he quickly assumes with how he gives
orders it's a moment that's simple and
concise in telling us a lot about the
character it quickly establishes his
personality and ruthlessness and it sets
him up to be one of the biggest threats
the heroes have seen so far in the story
that's what makes his eventual
development even sweeter looking at it
from the perspective of story writing
who knew that this ruthless tyrant would
undergo the level of transformation he
did when it's all said and done
next up we have muzan
[Music]
muzan's debut for me is one of the more
unorthodox ones for one there's no show
of strength in a direct way there's no
big confrontation against dangerou or
someone significant all we've got is him
being outed while perfectly blending in
with the crowd he does make a demon out
of a person a testament to his power and
the threat that he brings there's no big
battle like any of the previous entries
and just as suddenly as he appeared he's
gone quite a bizarre debut actually when
put against someone like say garo or
meruem however it's a decently strong
moment and after finishing the manga i
think it's great in a sense that in a
matter of a few seconds it easily
establishes the foundation of muzan's
personality moving forward the way he
does his thing the kind of villain he is
and how his end was don't make sense
after looking at his debut in retrospect
it's certainly a moment you'll
appreciate more looking back before
continuing how about taking some time to
thank today's video sponsors because if
you're more of a strategist than a
fighter perhaps this game will tickle
your fancy introducing samadhi mana a
game that i recently found and i just
can't stop playing sami d mana is the
latest in the popular genre of tycoon
games and you take the role of a hot
shot manager your goal helped baron
somebody build his army of undead for
him to return to the underworld in order
to do so you need to build farms manage
your resources recruit the best managers
and improve your structures to restore
the summity manor to its former glory
somebody mana will test your wits and
strategizing letting you spend hours on
end trying to find the most efficient
way to manage your resources be it
through training undead or upgrading the
proper structures other managers also
give you a helping hand and learning
their abilities and the bonuses they
provide can pay off big time in your
quest make sure to watch out for special
events in order to get even more perks
and rewards a fun game to pass the time
especially when you want to express your
brain muscles a bit somebody mana is
something i'd like to recommend to
everyone if you're interested in giving
this casual game a try all you have to
do is click the link in the description
box hours of fun and challenges await
from muzan's debut we move back to a
more action-packed one and here we have
what i think is one of the best anime
movie openers courtesy of luo lang in an
action movie that's heavy on the sword
fights and battles it's especially
important to establish the end villain
the final obstacle that the hero will
face in his journey and with the limited
time that a movie is compared to a
series sword of the stranger wastes no
time in establishing luo lang's threat
level it's a moment like gotos we've got
one guy laying waste to an entire squad
but take note that luolang doesn't have
any alien powers backing him up he's
just that good he's just that powerful
to make mince meat out of the entire
battalion this is the villain that our
hero must face in the end the ultimate
challenge and it will take everything to
have the slightest hope against this
monster
all for one makes its way to the list in
a big way
[Music]
for so long we've heard of the name all
for one the ultimate villain who's the
antithesis to all might status as the
beacon of justice and hope we've known a
lot of things thanks to his reputation
but we never really saw him in action
that is until we finally did almost no
one knew who this person was but the
look on their faces says it all that's
the look of pure fear and awe as all for
one stands over the wreckage his mere
presence slowly eradicating all hope
from the hearts of all heroes in sight
it also helps that he defeated best
genius with ease this physical debut for
me is all about the hype after
everything we've heard we finally saw
him in action and he didn't disappoint
one bit it's gonna take a miracle for
the heroes to get out of this and we did
get it in the clash against all my
giving us what i feel is one of the best
final battles in anime well it's not
literally a final battle but it's one
that marks the changing of the guard it
felt like saying goodbye to the mha have
come to know when that battle ended
[Music]
but suro is up next
[Music]
utsuro as a character always carried an
air of mystery before and after his
debut if i were to make a comparison
from menchie's on the list i consider
his debut to be like muzan's not in the
not doing any fighting department
because he sure showed his power and
beat everyone but in the way that he
looked like um for lack of a better term
an npc even the protagonist didn't
expect to face one of the most
overpowered characters in all of anime
when they took on some random masked
dude but here we are talking about how
utsuru made a memorable debut winning a
three-on-one with ease talk about a
twist and given what we see from witsuro
as the series goes on it's crazy to
think that he's not nearly in full power
when this happened this is like some
warm-up for the guy who will eventually
dazzle us with his combination of skill
and downright broken powers
as we start rounding off this list i
must talk about one piece amongst the
villains kaido is always going to be one
of my favorites and that has to do with
his debut
who among you one piece fans could ever
forget this skydrop that shook the earth
from the vantage point high above the
sky kaido easily towers over the feeble
weaklings as he quickly makes his
presence felt in a huge way both
literally and figuratively i think that
what helped make this moment is the
endless stream of hype as he's making
that big drop you get those claims
reserved for only the strongest of the
strong a be so powerful that all that's
left was for him to search for a place
to die a character who's been hardened
so much by the endless tribulations he
had to overcome before add to that the
claims of immortality and we know we're
dealing with something insane here the
stomp on everyone was just icing on the
cake a means to justify the hype
for our last stop we have madara
[Applause]
seriously is there any villain debut in
battle shonen that can compare to this
for so long we've heard about the
exploits of madala how he's a character
who left quite the legacy someone who's
a pillar of history and one of the
strongest characters but to see him
revived in an action and to see him solo
desecrate an entire division without
even breaking a sweat this is the
perfect endgame boss material for naruto
after all the craziness we've seen
through over a decade of the anime i'd
argue that he doesn't need such a strong
debut the hype's already there his
freaking mother in the flesh yet he
continues his rampage justifying the
hype and continuing the momentum of his
debut his favorite moment of mine had
him flex over the gargays in one
haunting movement and he also gave guy
his divining and most badass moment so
we've got to thank him for that too
right gaguya shouldn't have come into
the picture honestly but of course kishi
had to find a way to write him out
because he made madala too powerful
pretty funny metacommentary when you
think about it
and that wraps up the list did you find
the villains that you're looking for do
you know that you can connect with the
vinnie tube community through social
media if you didn't now you do that's
why i'll be leaving a link in the
description box for the channel's
discord channel you can also check out
our other social media outlets drop by
for news on our instagram page and if
you're feeling kind enough to donate
then do check out our patreon too thank
you for watching the video i hope you
had a good time and i wish to see you
again
you